Welcome Back everyone this to be my full venom let there
be carnage post credit scene video is a bunch
of stuff we have to talk about a bunch of
Easter eggs they just blew the multiverse wide open
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get everything in obviously
spoiler warning for venom let there be carnage.
If you haven't seen the movie yet.
Because we have to talk about everything that
happened in how they completely changed the
makeup of marvel movies as we know them.
So far is only one actual post credit scene.
This is the big thing.
Everyone's talking about.
But at the end of the film Eddie in venom
wind up eating both Cletus Kasady in the carnage
symbiote seemingly killing them.
But then they take off to avoid being arrested
by Detective Patrick Mulligan for killing
carnage and for being venom because during
the movie he's under threat of going to jail
himself for being venom being found out if
her going around eating criminals is a vigilante.
So even though he escapes in his seemingly
teleported to another world in the post credit scene
He still a fugitive in his original universe.
The probably address that and more venom sequels
at some point.
But the actual post credit scene begins with
he in the venom symbiote, hiding out in a
remote rundown looking ramshackle hotel room
watching a telenovela TV show.
Even if you don't speak Spanish the basic
plot of the telenovela references the venom
symbiote having offspring like carnage and
potentially having more offspring.
Like toxin antivenom other symbiote in the
future.
The man in the program that they're watching
a surprised to learn that the woman is pregnant.
Like what but then to try and make Eddie understand
what the symbiote is been through bring them closer together
Like understand the symbiote just better in
general venom offers to show Eddie Brock some
of the hive memories of all the symbiote going
back to the Big Bang and extending across the multiverse
That's right.
The phrase he says is 80 billion ly of hive
knowledge across universes would explode your
tiny little brain.
The reason why this phrase is a huge deal
is because not only does reference the hive
mind extending across the multiverse.
Like light years is also unit of distance
we talk about distance across the universe
across multiple universes memories going back
billions of years.
Like genetic memory that the symbiote carry
with them is also a bit of a teaser for Knull
the god of the symbiote who predates the Big
Bang so just to be clear this is huge the
symbiote do have a hive mind in the comics,
but they were created by Knull he's a God
who came from the void of nothingness from
the chaos that existed before the Big Bang
like Shuma Gorath is a good example that the
same place in the dark elves came from in
Thor the dark world.
Like they were born before the universe before
the Big Bang happened after the Big Bang after
the rise of the celestials Knull took a piece
of his body and fashioned into a powerful
sword called the Negra sword and use it to
kill celestials in some versions of the comics,
he's the one who be heads to my the analyzer
the celestial here who later becomes nowhere
the Negra sword was effectively the first
symbiote called the primal symbiote in people
who bond with it can use it to control massive
groups of other symbiote is like their biologically
link to it.
Like an alpha symbiote eventually the regular
symbiote's are born of Knull and become their
own race with their own identity.
But they saw the hive mind they rebel against
him, trapping him for billions of years until
in the comics, he escapes and seeks to recapture
his control them and take over the universe
to return it to the chaos of nothingness from
where he came.
It's kind of like with the dark elves were
trying to do during Thor the dark world destroy
the universe and return everything to chaos
that doesn't confirmed that they're going
to do Knull in the future venom sequels.
It is meant to be a reference to the origin
of the symbiote's in the ancient nature of their race
But when venom is starting to show Eddie it's
hive memories there's is glitching effect
that looks exactly like the glitching from
Spider-Man into the spider verse when the
characters travel between universes everything
in the room around Eddie starts glitching
out he freaks out the venom symbiote freaks
out and says that he's not doing it.
Like the symbiote says I'm not doing this
to.
However they're being transported to the main
MCU earth.
They're not responsible.
I think it has something to do with what Dr.
strange is doing with his spell during Spider-Man
no way home blending different universes different
timelines to make people forget about Spider-Man.
But when the glitching stops you can see the
room, there in is decorated way nicer it's
in the same location but there's towels folded
in the shape all around them on the bed confusing
the venom symbiote like what the hell is this
and instead of the telenovela that they been
watching on the TV the television in this
universe is tuned to a broadcast of J Jonah
Jameson yelling about Spider-Man killing Mysterio
referencing the end of Spider-Man far from
home you are a miscreant amassed marauder
for watching.
Don't forget to like them subscribe the venom
symbiote comes out and licks the image of
Spider-Man on the TV saying that guy.
Like we have business it is meant to be big
teaser for the Spider-Man venom movie that
they'll eventually do the end with a funny
taxing of the rooms actual occupant from the
main MCU universe walking out of the bathroom
just saying dude what the hell you doing in
my room and then it slams the black.
But now venom is in the MCU.
So that is a very huge deal.
If you predicted that was the way they're
going to accomplish this a couple years ago
and pat yourself on the back there a lot of
you asking why is venom suddenly so interested
in Spider-Man having never known about him
before like this is the first time it seems
like he's seen Spider-Man even though per
the symbiote's own explanation just a few
seconds ago that it's hive mind extends across
the multiverse across billions of collective
years of symbiote the living across all existence
should in there been symbiote's inside the
main MCU universe at some point that would
have learned of the existence of Spider-Man
I feel like you use the Loki series and he
who remains Kang to explain away things like that
Like obviously this is brand-new plot that
they didn't plan on 10 years ago and they
start of the MCU.
But because of circumstances in all the marvel
movies in the Sony movies.
They're trying to weave that all together
now and have it all makes sense.
So if you like everything doesn't completely
make sense right now.
I think it will make a little bit more sense
after Spider-Man no way home and as for why
venom is suddenly so interested in Spider-Man.
I think because he just meant to be pure is
like he just meant to be pure impulse just
like a cat or a little kid just looking around
being excited by shiny things he just fascinated
by what he sees playing out on TV as you probably
suspected because venom has gone all of his
movies so far with no Spider-Man symbol from
the comics on his chest this new Spider-Man
versus venom movie is the opportunity to do
that and to give Tom Holland the symbiote
at some point.
Although I am kind of holding out hope for
secret wars movie where they do a comic book
accurate version of Spider-Man getting the
symbiote the fantastic four.
Like, there's only one.
Like the red skull Capt. America is another
team of superheroes that I've worked with
computer bringing one of the X-Men and just
explain the timeline of when this scene is
taking place relative to the timeline of Spider-Man
no way home.
So the clip of J Jonah Jameson I think is
a clue because is not actually the same exact
scene from the end of Spider-Man far from
home is a slightly different clip like it's
a different broadcast at some point after
the end of Spider-Man far from home where
he still yelling about Spider-Man.
So, because of all the scenes of J Jonah Jameson
yelling about Spider-Man at the beginning
of the Spider-Man no way home trailer I'm
to go ahead and say this venom post credit
scene is happening somewhere near the very
beginning early part of Spider-Man no way
home and maybe there will be some similar
type of post credit scene at the end of no
way home for a moment during the movie that
acknowledges venom from the MCU side of things.
Like they did in the venom movie.
Now they have to do it in the Spider-Man movie,
but I don't think venom is going to be huge
character in no way home or anything like
that.
And here's the thing about Sony using the
Spider-Man into the spider verse visual style
of him traveling between universes that also
might have something to do with the Mdm. web
movie that Sony was developing a while ago.
Like the Sony people have been very open about
wanted to do live action spider verse up there
are kind of doing it already during Spider-Man
no way home.
Because of the Andrew Garfield and Tobey Maguire
stuff going on in the movie.
But the way the Tom Hardy and Andy serkis
have explained the Spider-Man venom crossover
is that they'll do it as a separate movie,
like it won't be Spider-Man four or venom
three they still plan on continuing venom
solo movies with other villains and Sony and
Marvel want to keep making Spider-Man solo
movies in the MCU with other new threats to
the Sony president said that a lot of how
these movies will all work between universes
in their sinister six plans for another spinoff
franchise will make sense after Spider-Man
no way home and we arty know how they're using
the doctor strange spell, invoking the multiverse
combining elements from other universes, which
is where we get to the Tobey Maguire Spider-Man
and Andrew Garfield Spider-Man characters.
So really in the post credit scene here they're
just sweeping the venom character up and all
that stuff but the issue any extra explainers
or announcements about their plans for Spider-Man
and venom movies.
I'll make a new video about it will be talking
about this in the multiverse a lot as we get
more Spider-Man no way home trailers and doctor
strange 2 trailers where if you can believe
it is craziest Spider-Man no way home seems
doctor strange 2 is going to be so much crazier
with the multiverse.
I'm working on my full venom let there be
carnage movie breakdown and Easter eggs video
for the entire movie that will post on Friday.
So make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss that.
It of course will do more videos about Spider-Man
and venom crossing over in the next week or
so my full marvel what if episode 9 finale
video will also post next Wednesday to the
Hawkeye series will be like the next big thing
that's happening to and I will be doing episode
videos for that it have any big questions
about what's going on.
The post credit scene or twists or anything
from the movie.
Just write them below in comments and I'll try
to address it in my future bonus videos everyone
click here for my what if episode 9 finale
trailer video and click here for my full
what if episode 8 Ultron video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys next one!